Tributes around the city are piling ever higher.
As grief sets in, New Zealanders are finding
ways to express their sorrow over a massacre
in their Muslim community.
Police forensic work is continuing around
the mosques.
But the bodies of all of the victims have
been removed from the crime scenes.
For now it's still a crime scene.
But police are picking up flowers to take
closer to Al Noor mosque, where dozens of
people were slaughtered during their Friday
prayers.
On the other side of the park, Christian groups
gathered to pray for their Muslim neighbors.
One woman has brought an art project meant
to show the bond between all faiths.
"So this is an artwork that I did for today
for St. Patrick's Day.
I wanted to make something for the whole community
to acknowledge this sadness and sorrow and
that feeling of connection with the Muslim
community."
This man has found another way to show his
support.
"I've had quite a few people come and have
coffees and hugs so it's been nice.
I guess it's nice to see people just showing
up and showing their support and solidarity
which I think is what New Zealand is all about-
being open and welcoming and peaceful people."
The support for the victims is overwhelming.
Most here are satisfied with the government's
response to the murders, but they want to
know how the suspect slipped through the cracks.
They say more needs to be done to address
racism- and to combat far-right radicalization
"Maybe we can't help the people who already
feel like that but we can at least stop the
younger ones from replicating this if we can."
The message here is clear: that hate has no
place in New Zealand.